(operatic singing)
- There's something
about standing on stage
and thinking about the people
that have doubted me in the past.
Standing on stage and
thinking about the people
who I would say, "Hello.",
to and they would just look
at me and keep on walking.
It's in that moment when I'm on stage
when none of that mattered,
where people see me as
more than just a janitor.
I am Keanon Kyles.
I am an internationally
touring opera singer.
I've performed at Lincoln
Center and Carnegie Hall
and the Chicago Theatre, and
all these amazing venues,
but at the end of the
day, in order to support
those dreams and support
my life, I am a janitor.
(wheels rolling)
I am a janitor because bills are something
that is very real (laughs),
and as you get older, they get bigger.
The assumptions that
people have about janitors,
are that they are
uneducated, impoverished.
I cannot tell you how
many looks I've gotten,
and the side-eyes, because
they just think that,
"Oh, you're just a janitor."
It's so interesting
because they never took
the time to really know who this person is
that is cleaning up after them.
Being an opera singer is very hard.
It's not easy, technically,
because opera music
is very complex.
I meet with my vocal coach/mentor
once or twice a week,
but I, myself, rehearse
probably two hours on top
of that a day.
I am currently rehearsing
this lead role of Rigoletto,
for the Clyde Opera Group's production,
in Scotland.
(operatic singing)
Rigoletto is my first title role,
which makes this moment so amazing for me,
because the whole opera is
about him and his story.
Coming from being a janitor to starring
in a show is very empowering.
(operatic singing)
Being a janitor has humbled me
and has grounded me so much.
You have to hold onto
yourself because nobody
cares about your dreams more than you do.
(operatic singing)